la capitale libanaise est tapissé de
l'image de saad hariri le premier
ministre démissionnaire
nous sommes avec vous clament les
affiches qui se répandent depuis une
semaine une telle démonstration d'amour
pour le politicien sunnite aurait été
impensable ici un quartier de beyrouth
dominée par les chiites
avant l'annoncé surprise de sa démission
depuis l'arabie saoudite une décision
forcée selon plusieurs
alors qu'un mystère entoure toujours ses
allées et venues parfois un individu
bénéficient de ce genre de situation est
aujourd'hui le premier ministre hariri
et populaires même auprès de ceux qui ne
l'aiment pas d'un député ou le voyons
comme l'éveil de la dignité nationale
tu es la photo de saad hariri est
omniprésente le principal intéressé lui
manque toujours à l'appel
l'entrevue qu'il a accordée à 'future'
qui vit une chaîne qui appartient son
mouvement politique devait calmer les
inquiétudes de ceux qui sont convaincus
qu'il est retenu contre son gré en
arabie saoudite malgré sa promesse de
retour imminent
le gouvernement libanais sa population
doute encore qu'il soit libre de revenir
pour la population sunnite du liban
l'absence de saad hariri s'est non
seulement celle d'un premier ministre
mais aussi celle du chef de leur
communauté
dans le quartier de tariq al jdidé les
gens expriment aujourd'hui un espoir
ambivalent je ne sais pas peut-être
subit-il de la pression seulement dieu
le sait mais il va revenir
abdallah al habib un libraire et
collectionneurs dit qu'il préfère la
compagnie de ses livres poussiéreux à
celle des politiciens
ces derniers croit-il au liban ou
ailleurs se moque bien de ce qu'il
souhaite
le liban n'est qu'un pion dans un jeu
d'échecs entre les grandes puissances
régionales d'eau alcober
les grandes puissances veulent la guerre
elles auront elles ont l'argent et le
pays pays pour détruire le pays et
ensuite elles vont payer pour
reconstruire c'est tout après la syrie
l'irak le bahreïn et le yémen
la démission choc de saad hariri a
ramené le liban en première ligne d'un
bras de fer pour l' influence régionale
entre l'iran chiite et l'arabie saoudite
sunnite
salim tahar est un des rares sunnites du
liban à critiquer ouvertement la
politique régionale de l'arabie saoudite
pour lui le jeune prince héritier
mohammed bin salman est impulsif et a
fait une grave erreur de calcul au liban
c'est qu'on ait cassé le gouvernement
d'unité nationale
il ne fait que le renforcer à la faveur
du hezbollah a fait rire le décor est
sobre à uv le groupe qui était opposé à
saad hariri l'iran la russie fasse
accrocher à saad hariri
il fait face à une étrange paradoxe dit
il l'arabie saoudite vous les clubs
confronte le hezbollah mais le nouveau
saad hariri va selon moi adopté le
hezbollah et ces derniers vont le
maintenir dans son poste de premier
ministre
les amis je vais bien du calme a écrit
saad hariri sur twitter promettant de
rentrer au liban dans les deux prochains
jours
entre temps la campagne diplomatique du
pays se poursuit pour tenter de
clarifier les circonstances de la
démission fracassante de son premier
ministre
son retour au pays est considéré comme
la seule preuve possible qu'il est libre
de ses mouvements
la seule façon de faire taire les
rumeurs et les spéculations et peut-être
d'entamer un nouveau chapitre dans cette
crise politique qui prend des airs de
véritable feuilleton ici marie-eve
bédard radio-canada beyrouth